- Cette Ukrainienne armée
jusqu'aux dents annonce qu'elle s'enrôle
Un discours aux accents nationalistes et
au ton déterminé.
Olena Bilozerska a été tireuse
d'élite, puis officière
de la Marine, et elle est
aujourd'hui lieutenante
des Forces armées ukrainienne.
Elle nous parle depuis un bunker à Kiev.
Dans son bataillon,
la lieutenante Olena
n'est pas la seule femme.
Après plus de dix jours de
très fatiguée et ne dort que
deux heures par nuit.
Sur la toile, les femmes
ukrainiennes qui rejoignent
l'armée so
à la Seconde Guerre mondiale
dans l'Union soviétique,
où plus de 800 000 femmes
se sont engagées dans
l'armée rouge.
MARIE LAMENSCH, Institut montréalais
d'études sur le génocide et les droits de la personne
- Certaines parties de l'Ukraine
sont en guerre depuis 2014.
Donc, les femmes ont doucement appris
à se mettre dans la tête qu'il y allait peut-
être avoir conflit et que,
peut-être, elles devraient
apprendre à manier les armes.
Il y en a certaines qui étaient
déjà parties justement dans
le Donbass pour se battre
à côté des hommes.
- Avant l'offensive russe,
l'armée ukrainienn
Et lorsqu'elles ne portent pas
les armes, des Ukrainiennes
s'activent pour acheminer l'aide
et la nourriture aux soldats.
MARIE LAMENSCH, Institut montréalais
d'études sur le génocide et les droits de la personne
- Les femmes dans un conflit ont
un rôle actif, qu'elles prennent une diversité de rôles
que souvent Et ce que ça veut dire aussi,
alors que la paix sera faite,
qu'il faut impliquer les femmes
dans le processus de paix aussi
parce qu'elles ont justement
joué un rôle et qu'elles aussi
veulent décider peut-être
du futur de leur pays.
- En cette journée
internationale des droits
des femmes, des appels à la paix
ont résonné, même
à Saint-Pétersbourg, en Russie.
Et pour la lieutenante Olena
ce combat demeure celui de la liberté.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada